[Musique]
bonjour feldman tout merci beaucoup
d'être invités politiques ce matin cette
mère de fonte et un moment d'horizon
c'est le parti d'edouard philippe et
vous êtes candidat aux législatives en
seine et marne on parlera pas de votre
circonscription vous le savez c'est la
règle électorale et je signale quand
même que vous serez opposé dimanche à
marie pierre molina c'est la candidate
de la nuque on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentait un florent bissonnet
implique du centre normand bonjour merci
d'être avec nous a parlé des
législatives évidemment dans quelques
instants mais d'abord emmanuel macron
était en visite en ukraine hier frédéric
valletoux il était aussi au 20 heures de
tf1 trois jours avant le second tour des
législatives est ce que vous trouvez que
le calendrier est propice à escales pas
une forme d'ingérence dans la compagnie
c'était surtout quelques jours aussi
avant le sommet européen de la semaine
prochaine
donc c est ce sommet va regarder le
sujet de l'ukraine ça va être un des
sujets majeurs de l'ordre du jour du
calendrier européen donc je pense que
c'est plutôt à l'aune de ce calendrier
là qu'il faut regarder la visite de
emmanuel macron millet des voix tout
seul trois chefs d'états quatre chefs
d'état européens
italie allemagne roumanie france qui se
déplace je pense que c'est un signal
politique très très fort extrêmement
fort et évidemment quelques jours du
sommet européen qui doit décider du
calendrier de l'adhésion fin du principe
d'abord et du calendrier ensuite de
l'adhésion de l'ukraine à l'europe
évidemment c'était un déplacement majeur
dans cette perspective des législatives
et selon les projections la majorité
absolue est loin d'être acquise pour
emmanuel macway ce qu'il paye finalement
cette non campagne
il ya un climat général il ya un climat
général
la campagne déjà des présidentielles
avaient été marqués par parfois des
débats sur finalement on passe un peu à
côté d'un grand débat sur les grands
thèmes parce qu'il y avait la crise
sanitaire on était quelques semaines
après la cinquième vague parce qu'il y
avait un réel contexte international qui
a écrasé les problématiques nationales
et politiques nationales on retrouve un
peu le même le même schéma à l'occasion
de ces cesser ces législatives donc il
ya des débats sur le sur le terrain moi
je pense qu'il n'a pas tardé à faire
émerger le débat justement mais est-ce
que c'était à lui de faire émerger le
débat je pense qu'il est dit des choses
pendant la campagne et là les choses
pendant l'entre-deux-tours il l'a fait
il a dit des choses pendant
l'entre-deux-tours il a dit des choses
après aussi il a posé ce qu'allait être
le le quinquennat à venir à partir de là
je pense que c'est aussi un contexte
plus général qui est pris par saison
jeunes internationaux
il a été réélu à la présidentielle et
que donc ce n'était pas vraiment une
élection importante que la logique était
que les français lui donne majorité je
ne sais pas je pense de toute façon il
est logique institutionnelle qu'on verra
vendredi qu on verra dimanche soir
pardon c'est qu'effectivement jeu il y
aura je pense une majorité
absolue ou relative alors ça évidemment
je n'entrerai pas là dedans c'est ont
personne n'est capable de le dire et on
voit même que les écarts sont importants
dans les enquêtes d'opinion c'est pas le
sujet mais en tout cas il y aura il y
aura il y aura il y aura un point majeur
de la majorité présidentielle dans la
future assemblée
voilà potentiel en parler moi c'est le
sujet du mouvement horizons auxquelles
vous avez envie tony c'est ce que ce
mouvement sera là un peu la clé de voûte
de la majorité présidentielle bat pour
être la clé doute il faudrait qu'on
conçoit les plus nombreux je pense pas
qu'on soit parti pour être les plus
nombreux on avait 58 candidats investis
je pense que à l'arrivée on va pouvoir
former un groupe parlementaire est ce
que ce sera 25 est ce que ça sera entre
25 et 30
c'est ce qu'on vise on regarde ce qui se
passe dans les circonscriptions qui sont
concernés et on pense qu'on peut arriver
entre 25 et 30 donc ça sera peut-être un
peu moins ce sera peut-être un peu plus
si ce
ne sera pas une clé de voûte nom sera en
tout cas un élément devra composer avec
toute façon
compose avec nous
emmanuel macron n'est pas la majorité
absolue et ça vous arrange rap ap il ya
une majorité serré et plus horizon
radieux pas d'abord je sais pas ce que
sera la majorité dont on fait arriver
s'il a évidemment si une majorité
étriquée on va dire que ceux qui chaque
voix contre 1 et donc les voies
d'horizon seront compteront si la
majorité est très large on sera
peut-être moins entendu message d'hier
c'est la logique des choses quoi qu'il
arrive le soin d'edouard philippe c'est
que il ya une vraie présence d'horizon
loyal et fidèle à au projet présidentiel
mais jusqu'où
les tests ou est-ce que vous aurez une
forme d'indépendance coup je ne sais pas
mais en tous les cas et le schéma posée
par par edouard philippe est très clair
il ya loyauté entière il y en a des ions
projet présidentiel il ya un soutien
plein et entier aux candidats macron
aujourd'hui au président de la
république demain à son à sa majorité
présidentielle voilà donc je vais pas
oublier aussi les divergences
qui
doit philips est c'est très clair pour
lui lui il est pour un report de l'âge
de départ à 65 ans non mais c'est un peu
moins clair du côté des manuels mac os
que par exemple vous voterez à horizon
cette réforme des retraites si l'âge de
départ à 65 ans du fils bertrand mais ça
dépend ce qui est de l'ensemble des
aspects ce n'est pas une mesure dans un
package de réforme des retraites qui va
impliquer différentes mesures et donc
c'est d'ardon mais là je vous parle est
crucial je vous le dit assez
régulièrement quand vous parlez de
données boussole qu'est l'espérance de
vie en bonne 18 qu'elle est inférieure
en france de 3 à 5 ans et par rapport à
nos voisins il doit y ait un lien ou
européen est ce qu'il faut tenir
davantage compte de cette espérance de
vie en bonne santé oui c'est sans doute
effectivement un des critères qui
doivent être prises en compte dans la
réforme des retraites ya le lien le choc
démographique à l'équation économique et
effectivement la pénibilité de certains
métiers la reconnaissance de ces
carrières voilà donc c'est un ensemble
de mesures et qui doivent être regardées
bon mais dont vous allez clairement pesé
dans cette réforme par un très lourd à
calais
j'espère qu'on va peser sur tous les
débats et j'ai positivement je n'y
allais pas de dézaley
finalement ç'a eu ouïe a du mal oui
parce que je vais pas vous dire
aujourd'hui ça sera t on chez horizon
maintenant le l'âge de départ à la
retraite c'est non c'est pas c'est pas
tabou mais il faut comprendre que c'est
c'est un package global si c'était juste
une question de 2,2 d'âge de départ à la
retraite ça pour beaucoup c'est juste
une question d'âge ses pannes non sa fin
au faux
précédente
il a dit effectivement que pour lui il y
avait une perspective effet d'aller vers
un des parades à 65 ans mais qui étaient
eux mais il me semble qu'il avait moins
de 65 ans
qu il faut bien comprendre que l'enjeu
de la réforme des retraites elle est
globale effectivement il ya plusieurs
curseur qui doivent être regardées
l'apport de ce que sera horizon c'est
aussi le rapport au territoire
c'est aussi assez un parti qui fédère
énormément d'élus locaux donc c'est
peut-être ce qui monte mais ce qui
manque ce qui a manqué à la précédente
majorité par emmanuel macron lui parce
qu'il les connaît les territoires mais
ce qui a manqué peut-être effectivement
à cette majorité qui a été qui est une
essence spontanée de 2016 dans lequel
effectivement les élus locaux qui
avaient acquis un peu d'expérience a été
finalement peu nombreux et donc c'est
bien que cette majorité futur soit une
majorité dans lequel il ya des gens qui
ont des parcours des expériences des
regards un peu différent et que tout ça
se nourrissent ou bénéfices du projet
présidentiel justement si vous êtes élue
députée dimanche quel rôle souhaiterait
souhaiteriez-vous pardon jouer au sein
de cette majorité peut-être notamment
dans le domaine de la santé écoutez la
santé c'est un des deux grands chantiers
avec le président la république avait
d'ores et déjà
dit qu'il serait important c'est à dire
la cité vous rappelle que cette
président de la fédération hospitalière
de france oui il a cité deux priorités
l'école et et la santé se veut pas dire
qu'il ne traquent ces deux sujets bien
sûr mais qu'en tout cas ce sont des
marqueurs importants du quinquennat qui
arrive est donc évidemment sur les
sujets de santé cds sujet sur lequel
j'ai suffisamment plaidé à la tête de la
fédération spyder de france avec
l'ensemble des hospitaliers pour que y
ait enfin des réformes qu'ils soient
prises qu'ils soient mises en oeuvre des
réformes volontariste audacieuse
profonde passe le système de santé en a
besoin évidemment je vais pas me
désintéresser de ces sujets une fois
arrivé à l'assemblée si jamais
effectivement dimanche qui arrive jamais
des six mois aussi à toutes mes phrases
mais mais c'est normal donc si c'est le
cas et bien oui c'est des sujets sur
lequel mois-là la réforme de la santé
j'aimerais accompagner le quinquennat
parmi d'autres un mais en tous les cas
pouvoir effectivement amener ma vo
chapitre oui on va revenir sur ces
questions de santé mais pour terminer
sur les législatives et les questions
politiques est ce que la puissance du
groupe de gauche qui s'annonce va
finalement poussé emmanuel macron à
faire une politique plus à droite mais
qu'est ce que sera le goût de bouchon
c'est pas bien non plus parce que je
sens qu aujourd'hui oui alors
globalement oui mais là nous pèse sais
c'est un conglomérat de deux choses très
assez différente on sait pas très bien
d'ailleurs combien le groupe
parlementaire vont être de cette
alliance qui est juste un atrium 1,4 et
déjà donc donc cette cette alliance qui
effectivement regroupe défense qui une
fois que chacun aura repris sa liberté
n'ont pas grand chose à voir puisque il
ya quelques mois c'est fort cela n'avait
pas grand chose à voir il est français
en écologie on
verra jusqu'où ils vont voter oui pour
eux
non une alliance qui va exposer de toute
façon ça sera pas plein de groupes dont
vingt quatre peut-être plus on sait pas
donc savez des groupes différents et
chacun va reprendre un peu ce qui est ce
qu'ils essaient ce à sa spécificité on a
vu pendant la la présidentielle que ce
que disait madame hidalgo ce que disait
monsieur mélenchon ce que disait le
candidat écologiste ce que disait
surtout le candidat communiste tout ça
est et était loin de se ressembler donc
là pour l'instant tout le monde s'est
mis sous la même bannière mais c'est de
la tactique on est dans la tactique
comment savent avis sur cinq ans parce
que canto effectivement le fond des
dossiers va être le critère qui va
permettre à chacun de se repositionner
je pense qu'effectivement chacun va
reprendre ses billes et va reprendre sa
liberté donc on n'aura pas un groupe de
gauche très fort on aura des groupes de
gauche qui effectivement auront été élus
sous une même bannière mais qui vont
vite oublier une fois qu'elle exercera
passé presque deux ans semblait devoir
c'est la jsk vous êtes par exemple pour
passer un pacte de gouvernement
on verra on verra de toute façon
moi je suis favorable à ce que les
réformes qui vont arriver dans le
calendrier que le présent la république
et gouvernement voudront mettre dans le
calendrier du quinquennat soit les
réformes qu'ils soient recueille
l'assentiment le plus large parce qu'on
sait que
plus les réformes sont soutenus
politiquement plus elles ont de chance
et de force et non plus de chances
d'être maisons doivent être comprises et
qu'on me parlait parlait français et
donc à partir de là s'il ya des réformes
qui convainque mais
du contexte politique qui va naître de
dimanche soir mais effectivement il peut
y avoir une recherche de de consensus
texte par textes en fonction des feintes
et sur les grands textes sur les grandes
options sur les grandes réformes eu
également avec les socialistes
écoutent et il y avait des socialistes
qui étaient jugées très raisonnable
jusqu'à jusqu'à il ya quelques mois
après son parti qui vous il y en a un
qui nous rejoignent après son parti
d'enda d'un sous la bannière derrière la
bannière nous paie son centre a dû
d'examen gauche entre temps c'est ça je
sais pas je sais plus très bien quelle
est leur boussole à peut-être que je
disais tout à l'heure qui vont peut-être
reprendre leur liberté de penser et vont
redevenir à nouveau ce qu'ils étaient il
ya deux mois c'est à dire plutôt
raisonnable bon ben ça semble un peu
pourquoi pas discuter je ne mets pas des
ti de d'étiquette sur sur les gens
chacun se positionne en fonction des
tests gouvernement pousse rang est-ce
que la nuque elle rassemblement national
c'est la même chose pour vous non c'est
un peu différent je le disais à
l'instant parce que la nuque c'est un
étendard qui a été créé pour le tampon
électorale et qui m'a vite est oublié
une fois que dimanche soir les français
auront voté donc là reste que la frairie
nationale france insoumise c'est parfois
plus compliqué effectivement parce qu'il
ya un rapport à la république et un
rapport d'hier à l'apparence de
confettis classement national non c'est
plus compliqué
j122 de ne pas dire qu'ils sont très
différents du rassemblement national et
là dessus c'est vrai qu'il ya dans les
comportements de 2 les filles en les
propositions que portaient les filles il
ya une forme de radicalité et que
quelque part ça reste de l'extrême
gauche
le rassemblement national est de toute
façon à combattre quoi qu'il arrive ça
c'est ça c'est une option forte en tout
cas moi je me suis engagé en politique
aussi par rapport à ça ça veut dire
contre un candidat rassemblement
national à un candidat l afg vous faites
un choix bain en train candidats
rassemblement national un candidat es
les filles vous regarde effectivement
qui est ce candidat et les filles parce
que je le redis c'est en fonction du
candidat oui c'est pas un barrage
automatique c'est pas
bien sûr on va parler de la santé dans
quelques instants longuement avec
florent mais d'abord cette épisode de
canicule intense et précoce surtout que
connaît la france vous présidez florent
lundi la fédération hospitalière de
france vous êtes maire est ce qu'on vous
attend
alors on est mieux préparé que les
précédents canicule on est mal en tout
cas je l'espère et normalement on a tous
pris nous les maires des précautions
pour qu'effectivement des coups de fils
soit passé au personnage et on a
aujourd'hui des fichiers qui
fonctionnent qui sont qui sont plus à
jour qu'il ya quelques années on a pris
nos précautions dans les maisons de
retraite de la même manière dans toutes
les voilà donc on est normalement
on capacité de mieux anticiper ont fait
passer des messages il ya plus en amont
et il ya eu des alertes depuis quelques
semaines qui nous ont dit attention ça
arrive donc on a pu faire passer des
messages plus en amont donc n'ont été
séparées d'ailleurs pour les hôpitaux
c'est pareil dans les ehpad même si
justement s'agissant des hôpitaux où
vous disiez que c'était un printemps
particulièrement sous tension et ça
n'était jamais arrivé alors
permis qu il va ajouter aux difficultés
après la canicule de quelques jours
viendra pas perturber le fonctionnement
des hôpitaux si la canicule s'installe
pendant quelques semaines ça va être
plus compliqué parce que l'hôpital il
est un peu à l'os et et que les
personnels sont particulièrement épuisé
les organisations aussi donc aujourd'hui
on est plutôt préparer que ce soit les
mairies que ce soit l'ensemble des
acteurs publics à cette canicule donc
les canicules de deux jours voilà ça
quelques jours ça se gère
si cet été on retrouve des épisodes qui
sont beaucoup plus longs
en tout cas pour la partie hospitalière
ça a effectivement posera des sujets un
épisode de canicule c'est à peu près ça
peut aller monter jusqu'à un doublement
la fréquentation d'urgence donc pour les
territoires les plus concernés bien sûr
donc on peut foncier s'installe dans le
temps si ça dure pendant une semaine dix
jours donc on voit bien que ça peut
peser sur des hôpitaux comme le disait
qu'ils sont déjà particulièrement
touchés sur la santé de manière plus
globale
quelle est la première mesure à prendre
en matière de santé une fois la nouvelle
majorité parlementaire en place la
première la première c'est un signal
politique très fort très fort qu'eux on
va prendre le sujet à bras le corps ça
c'est pas une mesure déjà renoncé pas
une mesure si c'est une mesure parce que
c'est une mesure ce que ça jamais des
faits et parce que réformer la santé ça
va être plusieurs années donc il faut un
quinquennat pour ça donc on veut c'est
pas d'un claquement de doigt ou d'une
mesure qu'on va résoudre les problèmes
par contre s'il ya une volonté très
forte qui ait marqué avec des
calendriers avec des objectifs avec de
dire voilà cette année on va travailler
c'est le sujet était mise en oeuvre d'un
certain nombre de réformes il ya besoin
de ça c'est nécessaire après la première
mesure vous me le demandez c'est
effectivement la question de l'accès aux
soins puisque c'est le sujet majeur
c'est le sujet et on voit ce que plus je
vous proposais notamment que les
permanence des soins en établissements
hospitaliers en ville soit organisé
conjointement je cite chaque praticien
devra s'inscrire sur une ligne de garde
et d'astreinte en ville ou à l'hôpital
ah mais moi je pense comment fait-on ça
à court terme alors je pense qu'on a je
pense que c'est une obligation à moyen
long terme il va falloir régler moindre
des choses à moyen long terme
effectivement parce qu'on l'a aussi que
c'est pas une mesure d'urgence entre les
lits mais c'est l'urgence cet été
j'avais justement des messages de
demande depuis le mois de mars parce qu
on a vu les tensions dans les services
d'urgences à l'est et les 130 services
d'urgence aujourd'hui qui sont pénalisés
dans leur fonctionnement continu et
manque d'effectifs j'avais demandé à ce
qu'on puisse organiser dans prévision de
cet été qui va être effectivement très
difficile organiser les plannings de
vacances de manière à pouvoir poser sur
le calendrier le fait que les vacances
territoire par territoire des
professionnels de santé de manière à ce
que tout le monde ne partent pas en même
temps la cance c'est une mesure simple
dans toutes les entreprises ont fait pas
partir de là j'en ai tellement ben ça a
été fait dans quelques régions dans
quelques bassins ça a été fait de
manière non mais ça me paraît logique et
oui ça et qu'on est simple à mettre en
place on fait ça dans toutes les
entreprises mais quand je demande ça les
syndicats hospitaliers les syndicats
hospitaliers peu hospitalier saint
etienne libéraux me saute à la gorge en
disant que je veut interdire les
vacances des libéraux ce qui est
absolument pas le cas je veux juste vous
veillez à ce qu'il n'y ait pas des
départs dans un même territoire tous en
même temps des cabinets de ville de
manière à ce qu'on puisse effectivement
étalez les choses et pas faire peser sur
l'hôpital entre le 1er et le 15 août où
premier 20 août une pression trop forte
parce que dans certains territoires 80%
des cabinets de ville seraient fermés et
partie les gens partis en vacances en
même temps tout le monde a besoin de
vacances les libéraux aussi qu'ils
bossent comme des fous simplement si on
pouvait entre le 1er juillet et le 31
août mais est ce que c'est parce qu'elle
est scholem finalement l'indépendance
c'est un sujet et l'autonomie des
numéros
l'a mérité voilà faut la respecter moi
je ne veux pas qu'il faut pas
s'organiser autrement très clairement
soviétisée système ou nationalisés c'est
pas du tout l'objet c'est effectivement
que je pense qu'on va être obligé d'en
laisser pour ça y est je reviens à votre
question initiale nous revoir les droits
et obligations qui pèsent sur chaque
professionnel de santé il faut pas
oublier tout ce monde là est financé par
la solidarité nationale par la sécurité
sociale par les cotisations des français
et que à partir de là à partir mans il
ya un financement public il doit y avoir
la contrepartie la prise en compte de
missions d'intérêt général et l'accès
aux soins l'accès aux soins au nombre
passera à l'obligation d'installation
dans les territoires c'est aussi eux
désertification
ça peut passer en tout cas pas regardé
par des propositions qu'ils fassent
qu'on fasse pas l'autruche et qu' on ne
fasse pas penser qu'il n'y a pas de
problème d'accès aux soins des français
aujourd'hui puisque il est prégnant et
donc c'est aussi aux professionnels eux
mêmes de faire des propositions pour
faire évoluer les choses mais d'après
moi on ne fera pas l'économie de revoir
l'équilibré entre les droits et les
devoirs de chacun dans ce système sur ce
même plateau en novembre dernier vous
évoquiez la situation à l'hôpital public
toujours de certains médecins
mercenaires à 2000 ou 3000 euros la
journée de garde joue un site où on est
l'application delà de la loi ariste
d'une honda des députés et les oem de
mon département le loiret qui prévoit de
plafonner la garde 24 heures à 1100
euros malheureusement cette réalité n'a
pas changé c'est même elle s'est même
accru ces mêmes c'est à dire qui et
loire qui écoute et qui n'est pas
d'appliquer pour réguler elle n'est pas
appliquée parce que si on applique
aujourd'hui on referme je ne sais pas
combien de ces deux services aujourd'hui
dans les hôpitaux parce que aujourd'hui
nécessité pour le coup nécessité fait
loi c'est à dire qu'effectivement on
doit arriver à
résoudre la question prégnante c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui on les attend au
total public français on peut pas faire
appliquer la loi traite aujourd'hui sur
ce point la vie d'un produit c'est vrai
on en a demandé le report et et le
gouvernement a accepté le report de la
mise en oeuvre de cette loi parce que
sinon si on est trop drastiques aura
sont là on se prive de de milliers de
soignants qui eux se sont mis plein
comprenez que c'est compliqué oui bien
sûr c'est bon mais également d'un côté
on peut payer de manière un peu mes sens
hier certains praticiens mais je vais
aller jaud qui sont
rémunérés moi je dénonce depuis des
années ce système ça coûte un milliard
d'euros à peu près à l'hôpital un donc
c'est la rangée l'hôpital c'est 70
milliards d'euros oui c'est pas c'est
pas anodin 1 1 milliard d'euros par an
c'est que ces gars d'la sahwistes
milliards d'euros par intérim c'est le
coup de l'intérim salaires ccc médecin
mais il n'ya pas que des médecins est
aussi dès 10h30 hier mais c'est dire
c'est surtout les médecins qui se
mettent en intérim parce
qu'effectivement ils gagnent jusqu'à
2000 euros barjots pour pour pour une
vacation donc
et la cohabitation se fait mal et c'est
pas bien pour le fonctionnement des
hôpitaux et ça mais l'hôpital a mal
financièrement et donc c'est un système
effectivement qui fragilise hôpital je
les dis
déjà le site l'intérim c'est un cancer
pour l'hôpital parce que c'est
effectivement quelque chose qui le
gangrène qu'il quelque chose qui le
fragilisent quelque chose qui le tue à
petit feu et il faut absolument tort le
cou mais pour ça il faut qu'on puisse
mettre des médecins dans les services
est malheureusement sauf à fermer le
rideau eh bien on a recours à l'intérim
c'est pas glorieux mais c'est comme ça
vous avez parlé des services d'urgence
en effet côté tout à l'heure 130 c'est
ça c'est votre chef 135
samu urgences de france a pour augmenter
si des mesures sont pas prises
effectivement d'urgence
isabelle borne et becker et brigitte
bourguignon en ont annoncé quelques unes
sont suffisantes alors aller au delà
d'après moi c'est rapidement et est
notamment faire comprendre la médecine
libérale qui sont aussi partie prenante
de cette de cet enjeu de santé publique
et que tous ensemble main dans la main
doivent trouver des solutions
effectivement ça peut ça peut aller au
delà rien dernier mot puisque les
chiffres du cor vide augmente à nouveau
un ace que les hôpitaux seraient à même
de gérer une nouvelle vague d'attaqués
avec la vaccination qui a progressé
aussi et la couverture vaccinale qui
fait qu'effectivement il y a moins de
france est extrêmement fragile et sans
doute que les loyers y aurait moins de
français en réanimation à l'hôpital
peuvent faire face la question la plus
difficile c'était la question
effectivement de tous ces cas graves en
grand nombre qu'il fallait prendre dans
les services d'urgences qu'il fallait
prendre les services de réanimation et
qui déstabilisait l'organisation
l'hôpital on peut et il faut espérer je
suis pas devin et je suis pas mais ça
non plus et encore moins 10 p et puis
des biologistes il faut espérer qu
effectivement la reprise de covin ne
s'accompagne pas d'une augmentation
importante des cas graves et des cas
compliqués à prendre en service de
réanimation parce que notamment dans les
transports au gouvernement
là dessus moi j'ai toujours suivi les
autorités de santé j'ai aucune
compétence pour dire s'il faut remettre
au pas les masques donc si les autorités
de santé au disque il faut le faire bien
il faudra effectivement le faire
gentiment et de manière précoce que deux
ce sera le mot de la fin merci d'avoir
été notre allié fort on regarde la une
de la république du centre les
législatives
[Musique]